foreign
we have Nick in Austin Texas hey Nick
welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking the call
absolutely how can we help
so my business partner and I built a
spec house right outside of Austin and
it's currently listed on the market for
a million dollars and if we sell at that
price we'll profit three hundred
thousand
and from that 300 000 we're going to cut
ourselves each a check of a hundred
thousand and then put the remaining
hundred thousand back into our business
account
and so I was just wondering how do you
what do you recommend for me to invest
that hundred thousand to start Building
Wealth
get out of this partnership ASM I was
going to say I wouldn't do the
partnership Nick yeah I wouldn't do that
but that's not why you're calling so go
for it Rachel like let me ask you this
how are you floating this note right now
because you got a 700 000 mortgage on
this thing how y'all floating that note
uh it's a construction loan and we're
paying it paying the interest basically
out of our own pockets what's that note
uh
500 000 construction loan we're paying
10.9 interest
but what are you paying every month what
are y'all splitting
we're splitting about 4 000.
so two grand where are you getting the
two grand
uh for my uh my regular job which I make
about 75 000 a year okay wait there's no
way that there's a 500 000 loan that's
four thousand you're putting in four and
he's putting in four
no he's putting in which putting it too
well they're paying the interest it's
just oh just interest okay so and you're
making a banker rich man you're hooking
them up
okay yeah it's our first one so we had
to bite the bullet on this High interest
not really but go ahead all right go
ahead
um okay so Nick where are you
financially what kind of debt do you
have
I have no debt okay what except for a
half a million dollar mortgage of a
house you don't live in except for that
except for that okay uh Nick how much
money do you have in the bank
um
I have about fifty thousand dollars in
crypto and stocks and in the bank ready
to go I have about eight thousand okay
oh you're incredible you watch a lot of
Instagram don't you how old are you Nick
27. awesome awesome okay here's what I
like about you Nick
you're running a gun like you're doing
stuff no it's a gangster dude he's
awesome yes okay
um can we just like give you like a
whole Money Makeover right now like if
we were to if John and I were to like
invade your home Nick and you're like
help me with every part of my money not
just what to do with this hundred
thousand but my life let me approach it
this way can we like to speak in and can
I ask it I'm gonna ask it this way okay
how long have you been has this house
been completed how long has the
construction been completed
two months two months okay
and if you're like me at all
you've long since spent this hundred
thousand dollars
and probably when y'all are fantasizing
about it was gonna be 1.2 or 1.3 but
it's down to 100 Grand you long spent
since you've long since spent this money
in your mind and every month
your chest is getting a little bit
tighter and a little bit tighter and
you're starting to go
whoa right and so here's what we're
offering you
you've got your way bro you've got
crypto you've got the whole thing you
are doing like The Tick Tock Instagram
Playbook down to the like the T
do we have your permission to offer you
just another vision of what your life
could look like absolutely please do all
right let's do it amazing okay so here's
what I would do Nick I would cash out
the 50 grand out of crypto and out of
single stocks
and I would just put that in a brokerage
account just to have
um because we'll just we'll do some
stuff with that later with that 50 Grand
I would add the 100 Grand to it so you
have a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
um of your money so I would not go back
into real estate deals like what you're
doing because it's very risky uh and
even though it seems like yeah it's a
done deal to John's point when you keep
taking on this risk and as the market
fluctuates if a buyer doesn't come if
your friend who I'm sure is a great
friend does something crazy and nutty
and all of this like I mean there's just
so much risk and what you're doing
especially if you continue down this
road you're it's gonna it's it there's a
there's a greed Nick that can start to
creep in where it's like oh I can do
that I'm gonna do that and you start
piling on this mindset that ends up like
coming into just a lot of risk and a lot
of debt so I would just stop that road
completely so after the sale of this get
everything get everything going and then
I would go back and say okay I'm making
75 grand I have a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars what's the wisest thing
for me to do I would take uh a chunk of
that because you have eight Grands just
in savings which I think is is plenty
for a three-month emergency fund or
you're single are you single yeah I have
a girlfriend but yeah awesome okay
perfect so yeah that eight grand can
just be an emergency funds kind of a
placeholder over here and then I would I
would invest this money Nick do you have
a primary residence do you own a home
I rent an apartment in Austin awesome
okay do you think Austin will be a
long-term place for you
yeah for at least the next five ten
years perfect okay so what I would do
Nick is I would buy real estate with
that hundred and fifty thousand dollars
uh and that's a that could be it'd
actually be 200 000 because I would not
put that other 100 into some
pseudo-joint business account that y'all
just gonna put down on another house so
take split that up you each take 150.50
yep wipe your forehead and Go whoo we
made it on this one we got real lucky
and then don't ever do speculative real
estate again yeah and I would do and I
would I would use some of that I would
invest some of it Nick maybe 15 of that
lump sum go ahead and invest it do you
have a 401k at work
I have a Roth IRA there you go perfect
yep I would go ahead and Max that out go
ahead and just put some money in that
for the year get that going and then use
the rest of this I mean I would look to
you know get a down payment on a home
because obviously you love real estate
Austin's a great Market I mean it's so
popular
um but I would find something you know
even if it's a town home for you that is
a 15-year fixed rate mortgage that's the
payments no more than 25 of your
take-home pay put a good down payment on
a home
um and start working to to pay that off
because what I want for you Nick when
you look up in five years for your life
to be yours not attached to a business
partner not attached to
um all this these real estate deals that
are out there and you're hoping are
going to sell and that it's going to end
up you know it's going to end up okay
because this deal did not every deal
does it hasn't yet but it might oh
that's true it hasn't even sold yet yep
um and I would and I would just be
investing and then on the side Nick once
your primary home is paid off then then
I would say okay yeah you're a smart guy
so so start saving up some money on the
side and get you a small rental like go
go find a a condo or an apartment or
something something small to buy dip
your toe in and actually own the real
estate instead of doing all this
flipping and new construction actually
own it get equity in it and and play the
real estate game that way versus what
you're doing is what I would do
personally let me tell you like in my
house this is me and my wife and my kids
I am I am right now putting money in a
money market account every month
I'm just hoarding cash and you know what
I'm waiting for I'm waiting for there to
be another dip in the market and I'm
gonna come buy your house for five
hundred thousand dollars
because you're gonna have to get out of
it at some point you can't keep robbing
Peter to pay Paul and there's going to
be a whole bunch of real estate across
this country in the exact situation you
and your partner are in where you had a
million dollar dream that turned into a
half a million dollar nightmare all you
do is pay an interest in this machine is
just growing and growing it's it's
getting heavier and heavier and so I'm
I'm just gonna wait until I can pay for
something with cash and so what we're
telling you is not something that we
just made up for fun this is how we live
our personal lives and I'm gonna buy
real estate at a discounted price with
cash that's going to be mine and nobody
can ever take it from me and I won't
care what the interest rates are I don't
care any about that crap and me and my
wife are going to sleep so well I'm
gonna be able to help somebody in my
community maybe even with a little bit
of a compressed rent because because I
can right because I own it it's mine and
so here's what we're trying to paint you
a picture of a non-anxious life man a
life where you can breathe and you can
go hang out in Austin which is one of
the greatest cities in America and you
can go have fun and you and your
girlfriend can go just go out
and you are not unable to breathe
because every time you look up and
you're about to put your debit card down
for dinner you think I gotta spend two
thousand dollars just to get the
interest covered on this thing I hope
homeboy Pays His half because he may not
because he's been screwing around with
whatever you never know man and so we're
painting a picture that's slow and
boring and that will make you a
multi-multi-millionaire over the Long
Haul yep low
low risk the long game
and autonomy owning your life Nick not
Distributing out to all these other
people so thanks for calling